Buffalo Bills safety tomorrow Hamlin we
are hearing him speak for the first time
since he collapsed from a cardiac arrest
during game this month Hamlin posted a
nearly six minute video on social media
over the weekend thanking the medical
staff who saved his life and the people
who have been rooting for his recovery
watch this
as it was just a lot to process within
my own self mentally physically even
spiritually it's just been a lot to
process but I can't tell you how
appreciative I am of all the love all
the support and everything that's just
been coming in my way
Hamlin is recovering at home and
continuing rehab with the bills